and now ladies and gentlemen as the
tension begins to mount we come to the
first award for acting all the way from
her home in Paris France a city that has
seen some of the world's outstanding
performances Sarah Bernhardt Eleonora
Duse a nikita khrushchev here is the
talented winner of two Academy Awards
miss Olivia de Havilland
thank you thank you
because I remember all too vividly how
excruciating this moment can be for an
actor and his fingernails
I won't prolong it the nominees for the
best performance by an actor in a
supporting role a huge rip in Ben Hur
Arthur O'Connell in anatomy of a murder
George see Scott in anatomy of a murder
Robert Vaughn and the young
philadelphians and Edie win in the Diary
of Anne Frank may we reveal the winner
please Hugh Griffith in them hair
or for mr. you Grippit ducting from
non-stick you Griffith no I am extremely
happy to accept this highly deserved
award for mr. you Griffith for his
wonderfully humorous human and
sympathetic characterization of an Arab
Sheik my only regret is that the people
of the United Arab Republic would not be
permitted to see his performance